you want to get into Cloud without a  degree well here are the four tips that  can get you into Cloud without a degree  understand your Cloud path how do you  choose well rely on your current or past  work experiences and draw your Cloud  path from there  study for a certification just go  through the prep with an intention of  structured studying you don't really  have to get certified but the structured  studying will help you cover the  concepts you need to know in order to be  successful in a cloud role number three  do Hands-On labs this is the most  important part you need to see how  things work play with the tech make a  Hello World and number four build your  Cloud portfolio your certification Crews  that you have the knowledge but to prove  to an employer that you'll be able to do  the job you need to show that you can  put that knowledge to effective business  purposes so go ahead use these four  steps and make a plan for your Cloud  Journey